I warren how important is the keyword difficulty value?
I don't pay attention to that what I look at bro is and if you're talking about like on some of these tools like
Keyword difficulty blah blah blah
I would pay attention to how it is compared to other projects, but I'm looking at the CPC
And I'm looking at the due diligence sheet as a whole because if I'm going into tree service
I'm trying to rank for tree removal
Tree service tree cutting tree trimming stump removal
I'm trying to rank for all those and so just because one of those is really difficult according to the tool
Doesn't mean that all of them are difficult and I'm looking at it as a whole and so I don't really pay attention
I think it would be valuable to maybe look and see how they compare but keep in mind the tools
The tools are wrong. It's only about comparisons